ساعه سواء كانت انفراجه ام التفافه فان
موافقه المانيا على ارسال بولندا للدبابات
الى كيف لم تلبي طموحات اوكرانيا التعنت
الالماني بارسال الدبابات يعتبرته دول
اوروبيه خروجا عن السرب وخطوه تكرس انقسام
المعسكر الاوروبي في ملف الحرب وتؤكد ان
برلين خائفه من روسيا لكن امام التعنت
الالمانيه تخرج بارقه امل للاوكرانيين بعد
اعلان بولندا عزمها ارسال دبابات ليو فرد
الالمانيه لاوكرانيا عاجلا ام اجلا وتاسيس
تحالف من دول مستعده لارسال الدبابات كما
جاء التطبيقات اوروبيه اليوم بمواصله دعم
اوكرانيا مهما طال الامر واتفاق الدولي
الاتحاد على ارسال حزمه سابعه من
المساعدات العسكريه الاوكرانيا بقيمه
بخمسمائه مليون يورو